topa Kansas inviting migrants to come to
its City apparently has too many open
jobs that are not being filled so
leaders there are offering $155,000
checks to anyone who wants to move the
city's Democrat mayor saying quote we
have to have people here who are willing
to work and make this the city they want
to raise a family in get a career in
Tommy lens and now kick host Tommy joins
me now Tommy Friday um much like the
request we see in sanctuary cities you
know this regret for uh come to our
state oh no don't come to our state will
the mayor be singing the same tune you
know if people actually take him up on
the
offer yeah I would say be careful what
you ask for and as much as this headline
and this story sounds incredible and
Incredibly ridiculous when I really
stopped and started to think about it
what this Topeka Kansas what this city
is doing really is no different than
what the United States of America is
doing on a large scale maybe they're not
being as direct and honest and
transparent about their goals but when
you have an open border you bring people
in you fly them or bust them to the city
of their choice you give them three
meals a day you give them hotel rooms
maybe you give them cell phones really
the United States government the Biden
Administration is doing what Topeka
Kansas is doing but on a much larger
scale they just won't admit to that but
that's what you're doing you're putting
the magnet you're telling people please
come but I think also here a warning
because this whole thing of we need
workers we don't have enough people to
fill these jobs that is the line that is
going to be used by democrats when they
try to justify Mass amnesty and of
course voting rights it's going to be we
need people to work so be careful for
that narrative it's going to come back
around yeah this mayor is driving home
the point look this money is only going
to people who get a job but to your
point you make a great point this is all
to lead to amnesty and I would argue
Tommy in this instance to keep Topeka
blue finally I got to get your thoughts
on this Democratic Squad member Ayanna
Presley claiming that Walgreens you know
the drugstore is racist for closing
stores in some crimer ridden areas
listen when a Walgreens leaves a
neighborhood they disrupt the entire
community and they take them and they
take with them baby formula diapers
asthma inhalers life-saving medications
and of course jobs these closures are
not arbitrary and they are not innocent
they are life-threatening acts of racial
and economic discrimination shame on you
walg
Walgreens is a multi-billion dollar
corporation that needs to put their
money where their mouth is it's all
about racism it has nothing to do with
rampant theft Tommy does
it you know today is Groundhog Day and
this is just a continuation of the life
cycle of democrat delusion so Democrats
cause a problem they advocate for
defunding the police they advocate for
Lawless felon coddling policies and then
when the ramifications of those policies
come home to roost then of course they
go to their old favorite racism but you
know she's saying these things about how
these communities these underserved
communities are are going to be
penalized when these stores move out of
the communities well she's exactly right
but who caused that and when you talk
about the Felon coddling policies and
the lawlessness and the shoplifting and
the justification in a lot of in a lot
of places for this shoplifting and other
Lawless activity yes it does harm black
and brown communities it harms white
communities it harms every color of the
rainbow it harms their communities so
when she's saying this and she's talking
about the consequences I hope she's
understanding the irony of what she's
saying because this is what her policies
and those like her advocate for and I
would also say this perhaps her fellow
Squad member Corey Bush who's under
investigation for possibly mishandling
security funds perhaps she could provide
some of her personal security to the
stores in this community and other
communities that are fing maybe then
customers and store owners would feel a
little bit more safe uh it's glad you
mention the squad it's been a week of
Whoppers from them Bush and TB welcoming
terrorists through their vote in the
Congress Omar running to be the
representative of Somalia Presley's like
I got to get in on the ACT I got to get
some press Tommy lren have a great
weekend we appreciate your time thank
you so much I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis